[Musik]
sie ist reformierte pfarrerin
er ist komiker und agnostiker und glaubt
nicht an gott
damit noch nicht genug das ehepaar
carolina und victor costa aus genns
trägt seine diskussionen und konflikte
in aller öffentlichkeit aus im internet
in einer web serie mit dem titel la
femme pasteur meine frau pfarrerin und
das durchaus erfolgreich
was treibt die beiden an wie sieht ihre
und familienalltag aus und wohin führen
eigentlich diese auseinandersetzungen
carolina und victor costa sind heute zu
gast in der staat und religion ja wie
ist es jetzt eigentlich wirklich aus
pastorin mit einem agnostiker mit einem
skeptiker verheiratet zu sein
ich sage immer also jetzt mit ein paar
jahren erfahrung ist mir bewusst dass
ich glück habe mit einem agnostischen
ehemann das ist ein ansporn für mich und
es hat mich auch verändert als dass ich
denke immer daran nicht ihn zu bekehren
aber mit ihm zu diskutieren und von
ihnen zu lernen
und wenn ich eine predigt mache versuche
ich mir vorzustellen er höre zu und ich
richte mich sein ihn also ein motor was
treibt denn dieser motor an
also ich da hat ihr inhalt in der
verpackung geändert ich habe eine
sängerin und pianistin kennengelernt und
mit der zeit ist aus ihr eine pfarrerin
geworben und ich bin diesen weg mit ihr
gegangen
genau ich wollte er noch wissen oder was
dieser motor bei ihnen treibt aber sie
haben schon geantwortet wie ist es denn
für sie auch skeptiker mit einer
pfarrerin haben sich daran gewöhnt
nein ich habe mich nicht daran gewöhnt
deshalb habe ich ja eine webserie
aufgebaut
aber jetzt sehe ich meine frau die ich
ja schon vorher hatte vielschichtiger
es hat mir wirklich neue horizonte
eröffnet auch in bezug zum tod
ich fühle mich ihm näher es ist schon
etwas seltsam wenn ich am abend nach
hause komme ich frage was hast du so
gemacht und dann erzählt sie von einer
beerdigung
das kommt nicht jeden tag vor aber man
denkt halt darüber nach und das geht
eine andere sichtweise
sie haben von einem motor gesprochen
unser bedürfnis ist doch immer die liebe
in unsere arbeit und unser zusammenleben
ist es immer die liebe im weiteren sinn
in unserem blog wollen wir von den
grundlegenden werten sprechen die
zusammenkommen bei einer pfarrerin die
glaubt und praktiziert grund war ein
agnostiker der eher rational und schauen
was dann passiert antrieb ist immer dass
das menschliche das menschliche die
öffnung das zusammenleben das und
wichtig ist in der tradition und auch in
deiner welt lustig macht oder auf diese
website
es gibt einzelne folgende schon deutsch
in deutscher sprache synchronisiert sind
wir schon mal in eine folge sein wie das
drauf schaut
[Musik]
thomas wollen wir die hier anwesende
klarer für frau nehmen
ich habe mich in eine frau verliebt die
bio zu sein wollte
in einem teil restaurant arbeitet durch
die welt reiste mit sozialistischen
kommunistischen idealen aber von dach de
hier ist wieder bekommen wie er ist bei
gott dem vater dem sohn und den heiligen
geist der gedanke eines trucks mit gott
zu schlafen
[Musik]
die blade kalt werden du mich ein
bisschen kommt erleichtert ich kann
nicht ich habe lampenfieber lampenfieber
der gottesdienst morgen früh mittel
kommen diese samstagabend seiner nein
ich kann nicht aber ich brauche deine
hilfe
kannst du mich abhören aber am meisten
beunruhigt mich was es ausmacht wer bin
ich jetzt guten tag wie geht es ihnen
guttenberg geht es besser wer ist der
mann der pastorin
wie bitte er ist der mann der pastorin
der mann der pastorin ja der mann der
pastorin
ich meine es gibt ja viele paare die
sind verschieden und tragen das aber
nicht in die öffentlichkeit was ist das
ziel was wollt erreichen mit dieser wenn
du sagen deine idee
wir dachten es ist schon sehr speziell
für einen agnostiker mit einer pfarrerin
zusammenzuleben
diese fragen über die liebe den tod das
leben waren immer präsent und vati mir
denn das mir so nahe geht kann das auch
andere nahe gehen
so haben wir ein format gesucht ich
dachte an eine webserie weil hier die
grenzen völlig offen sind
man kommt überall hin und alle können es
anschauen
und ja die zuschauer haben entschieden
sie haben unsere serie angeschaut dann
übersetzt auf deutsch italienisch und
dann hat sie eine weltreise unternommen
an die festivals will webserien ich
glaube unsere fragen sind den leuten
nahe gegangen
wir hatten ja schon erfahrungen gemacht
mit einer ersten serie lief willkommen
bei uns dort ging es um einen spanier
der mit seiner partnerin die schweiz
entwickelt davon haben wir über 100
folgen gemacht
schon die wahren humoristisch das ist ja
auch unsere welt wir sind zwei künstler
wir wollen etwas mitteilen von dem was
sie erleben wir versuchen mit anderen zu
teilen was uns antreibt
heute gibt es ja viele gemischte paare
geht uns darum zu zeigen dass das etwas
positives ist und dass man zusammenleben
kann mit verschiedenen religionen mit
unterschiedlichem glauben
sie sprechen die wurzeln die spanischen
wurzeln von victor costa und damit auch
katholische wurzeln also sind jetzt wird
durch ein agnostiker oder was glauben
sie jetzt werden sich
ich glaube stark an den menschen man
alles was er machen kann was in ihnen
steckt dann gibt es auch dinge die ich
nicht im griff habe auch die keine
antwort findet nie eine antwort hinten
werde seine oder höchsten für mich eine
ganz persönliche
mir ist es wichtig dass ich irgendwie
glücklich bin und das ist mein ziel
und daher sind es meine persönlichen
geschichten die ich erzähle
gleichzeitig sind wir ja alle agnostiker
nicht ungläubig aber agnostiker ich weiß
ja nicht ich glaube ich habe ja keine
beweise
also kann ich sagen ich bin eine
gläubige agnostiker in und du bist ein
agnostiker der etwas weniger glaubt ich
höre aus ihr wollt wirklich menschheits
vorhaben fragen die die menschen bewegen
wollte auf reifen ihr wollt auch zeigen
man kann wenn man verschiedene ist auch
einen weg finden gemeinsam aber mit
dieser website also in der
öffentlichkeit
das ist eine schöne pfarrerin es ist der
etwas
ich sag mal auf den kopf gefallen oder
etwas unbedarfte agnostiker
was wollte den leuten sie sagen ja er
soll so bleiben aber wollte er die leute
missionieren oder wir ihnen das leben
zeigen was alles hat mit seiner idee
angesammelt er wollte von unsere welt
erzählen und dann haben wir uns mit ein
paar kommunikation für auftraten der
westschweizer kirchen zusammengesetzt um
die gott robotern von genc fribourg
neuchâtel und von medien
er hat ihnen das projekt vorgestellt und
die kirchen waren wir schnell begeistert
primacom planten sie könnten uns
unterstützen und worin er ist also
wichtig zu sagen dass diese genommen
mutierten inzwischen das projekt
unterstützen auch finanziell abhängig
machen daneben auch die
deutschsprachigen version von 100
kirchen in der deutschsprachigen schweiz
und es gibt eine italienischsprachige
version von radiotelevisione svizzera
sie auch ausgestrahlt also schon breite
auf sie sagten sich dass sie dabei einem
projekt mitmachen könnten hinter die
managerin steht welche ihre werte
vertreten die ballonhülle in zadar für
sie war als eine gelegenheit ein
gewisses strenge se mit der kirche zu
entstauben zeit haben wir das problem
dass immer weniger leute in die kirche
gehen also müssen wir auf andere art zu
den leuten kommen eben übers internet zu
den jungen zu einer neuen generation
eine gelegenheit in diesem gebiet
präsent zu sein aber ohne uns zu
zensurieren haller und dass da ein
agnostiker ist macht das ist ganz klar
kein missionarisches projekt ist für uns
ist es vielmehr ein projekt präsent zu
sein
was mich betrifft als agnostiker
ich arbeite mit anderen autoren zusammen
darunter sind auch atheistische und das
geht dieser website stecken
der tag ist es wohl auch von den
verschiedenen festivals angenommen
worden und in die wettbewerbe gekommen
an diesem festivals am anderen ende der
welt in amerika wussten die leute nicht
hat auch die kirche dahinter steht das
ist eine echte pfarrerin ist und in den
workshops sind sie dann fast vom stuhl
gefallen sie konnten es nicht fassen
bedenken dass sie so ein bisschen der
ball geber sind dass sie so ein bisschen
eingespannt werden in wärme seven viele
kirchen die das sponsern dass sie da in
ein werk ist oder kirchen rein geraten
sind
als ich mit dem welchen kirchen
arbeitete bestand ich darauf dass am
schluss ich entscheiden würde aber klar
von der theologischen seite hier können
sie mich beraten damit alles stimmt aber
am schluss der schnitt gehört mir
daher fühle ich mich sehr freuen wenn
die braut und sie autorin haben ja in
genf auch noch ein projekt lola also ein
versuch sag ich mal die kirche auch in
anderen formen unter die leute zu
bringen die leute zu animieren was
machen sie doch auch hier geht es darum
eine neue generation zu erreichen um
eine art labor also einen ort wo man
sich auch einmal mit jungen leuten neue
wege suchen wir versuchen zum beispiel
zu schauen wie das ist mit der
meditation weil heute viele leute
meditieren also wie wir die meditation
und die christliche spiritualität
zusammenbringen können frösche
fachplaner bruder unser projekt wo wir
mit homosexuellen und transgender
gruppierungen zusammenarbeiten
da haben wir einen raum geschossen wo
die jungen aus dieser gemeinschaften
ihren glauben und ihre religion und ihre
orientierung zusammenbringen können
wirbt riverbed es wichtig weil sie von
vielen religiösen traditionen
ausgegrenzt werden und wir sind hier
sehr offene ehe partner das projekt
meine frau pfarrerin ist ja etwas
ähnliches das heißt es geht nicht darum
zu missionieren
sondern unsere art ist es jetzt spricht
er mich als pfarrerin dialog auch in
solchen fragen
aber es ist schon auf diesem weg dafür
hoch kirche in anderen formen zu sehen
das habe ich schon richtig verstanden ja
aber gleichzeitig spielen wir mit den
vorgefassten bildern die ist ja wirklich
auch in einer kirchgemeinde hattet
ältere leute mit etwas altmodischen
einstellungen und entsprechende
diskussionen die kompakt spielen wir
halt mit der realität wo du dich
gesungen
gleichzeitig ist mir auch bewusst dass
ich wohl eine eher fortschrittliche
pfarrerin bin also wir wollen mit all
dem spielen aber offen gesagt das
wichtigste ist die leute zum lachen zu
bringen
das erste gang des managers ist gar
nicht so einfach gibt an dass fußball in
unserem gebiet wo es uns spaß macht
gewisse biblische texte zu zerpflücken
und vorurteilen und wenn wir es schaffen
die leute zum nachdenken zu bringen
haben wir gewonnen
mehr wollen wir eigentlich gar nicht es
hat auch was leichtes sie gehen auch ins
persönliche reihen als gedauert die
frage partnerschaft
schauen wir uns mal nacheinander beitrag
an wo es eben dann so um ihr zu sagen
gibt
mit einer pastorin als frau werden
manche dinge zum abenteuer liebling lass
uns den urlaub plan fahren wir in ein
bundesland ja griechenland mag okay
griechenland dann können wir ja fliegen
sie fahren will ich bin auf dem weg war
die der gemeinderat okay das ist ein
block von nur fünf minuten sagen wir
manche dinge werden komplizierter du
durch bist seine sexuelle neigung
liebling ich und du kannst sie nicht
nicht ausleben wirklich ihr alltag ist
schon etwas weh getan
ich kann nicht etwas schreiben dass ich
nicht fühle oder erlebe das wirklich
etwas wahres dran
ja ich meine so störungen das erleben ja
viele paare wollen sie eigentlich
vorbild sein
wir sind kein vorbild aber vielleicht
stehen wir für viele andere paare die
medien haben sich zu organisieren oder
bond oder von der arbeit her gesehen
alles geht schnell absorbiert und hat
kaum zeit für die beziehung in den
gruppen sind wie repräsentativ
es gibt eine folge über die eifersucht
und dann gibt es situationen die typisch
für das leben eine pfarrei sind wäre es
geht auch darum zu zeigen dass ein
fahrer nicht jemand ist der da oben
steht etwas perfektes bei dem alles
stimmt dass ich noch ein paar eine
pfarrerin ist im alltag gefangen wie
alle anderen und er besucht die worte
von liebe und frieden wirklich zu lieben
aber auch er hat seine schwierigkeiten
und schwäche
solche dinge wie unsere wechsel zeigen
und gleichwohl gibt es ja noch nein bei
einer pfarrerin eine dimension dazu oder
nämlich mal als rituelle dimension haben
ja auch ein buch geschrieben ziadeh sie
caroline agusta da geht es eben um das
leben zu zweit in einer partnerschaft
und das buch wird bald in deutscher
sprache erscheinen sie sich ein
spielerisches buch also es gibt texte
darin es gibt aber auch seiten die leer
sind die man dann ausfüllen kann wo man
einen weg gehen kann
was ist denn das rezept für gelingende
baut muss zwei dinge sind wichtig die
kommunikation leben aber damit ist
eigentlich noch gar nichts gesagt
es geht nicht nur darum miteinander zu
diskutieren sondern einander zuzuhören
es ist ja so dass man schon über seine
antwort nachdenkt während der andere
noch redet statt wirklich zuzuhören was
er sagt warum sie gut weil sie die ganze
kommunikation ist wichtig und dann noch
das ich kannte ein älteres paar in genf
das seinen sechzigsten hochzeitstag
feierte und auf meine frage gewissheit
dass die lange funktioniere antworteten
sieht es ist der humor meine liebe humor
ich kann das bestätigen
dann habt ihr gute chancen oder dass es
lange geht
ich glaube schon
wir haben sie das buch gelesen am anfang
war ich das versuchskaninchen
sie hatte so zettl und die hat sie an
mir ausprobiert ist also zuerst war ich
die testperson und danach war ich der
lektor ich schaute auf die linie des
buches im hinblick auf die zeichnungen
und die texte report is a
dort wächst weil er aber was mich
antreibt ist die liebe und wie carolina
sagt manchmal glaubt man seinem
gegenüber zuzuhören
aber es sind ja nicht nur wörter die aus
ihrem mund kommen sondern dahinter
stehen gefühle und ihr können manchmal
das gegenteil sein von dem was sie sagt
und ich zu verstehen muss man diese
entschlüsseln
es braucht viel geduld und liebe
zusammen
also was ich raus gezogen hat ist auch
die arbeit oder die arbeiter in der
beziehung also dieser weg von dem
verliebtsein ist eben zu der liebe was
sie sehr schön bescheiden was ich
vermisst habe ist das geschrei der
kinder das ist die termin schlag das
täglich gewitter an terminen wo man
irgendwie versucht das leben zu
gestalten und ja klar aber es geht auch
um den moment wenn man nicht glücklich
alles ist in ordnung
es gibt fahrer die sich sagen jetzt
heiraten wir jetzt verbringen wir unser
leben zusammen und alles ist super
und dann kommen die kleinen
schwierigkeiten und konflikte und geht
es darum zu zeigen dass die ehe nicht
nur diese eine tolle tag ist sondern es
sind die vielen jahre die danach kommen
ich spreche nicht über die vielen
konflikte sondern über den ursprung der
konflikte über die auseinandersetzung
mit der eigenen kindheit in einem
konflikt wiederholt man ja die
verletzungen die einmal als kind
zugefügt wurde es steht alles im buch
[Musik]
bietet ihm lieben als para darum zu
lernen was es eigentlich bedeutet zu
lieben
es ist nicht nur die liebe am anfang
alles romantisch und toll wenn es geht
wirklich darum zu lernen all die zeiten
zu überwinden in denen es schwieriger
ist das wort jesus oder soeben
spiritualität in der partnerschaft das
kommt nicht so lustig aufgetragen saison
bisschen rücksichtnahme
sie sagt jesus ist liebe verstehe ich
dass das schon aber beim rest habe ich
noch viele fragen
ihr seid euch nicht auch theologische
knacknüsse in euren folgen auf zu bergen
noch in eine folge kurz rein da geht es
um das gottesbild
[Musik]
ich hätte nie gedacht dass meine frau
eine revolutionären ist woher das wohl
kommen mag
[Musik]
hahaha ein paar wird von mir trauen das
weil ich eine frau bin und beruhige
wenn es so weitergeht heißt es eines
tages die kirchen sind wegen der
pastorinnen lehrer werde sich auch
ungewöhnlich ein moment jesus war vor
2000 jahren von frauen umgeben und heute
ist das ein problem
ja unser stärkster vor revolution genau
jeden sonntagmorgen mit nackten brüsten
predigen wie die film darum nicht von
mir aus gerne ich bin in der ersten
reihe
so beginnt die revolution im eigenen
haus bei allem humor was haben sie
herausgefunden ist gott jetzt männlich
oder weiblich
[Gelächter]
offensichtlich sehen wir jetzt auf
deutsch weiter gebiet ehrlich gesagt
dieser sketch entstand nachdem gottfried
locher
er wird mir verzeihen dass ich das
erzähle diesen unglücklichen satz gesagt
hat wonach die frauen die pfarrerinnen
für die leeren kirchen verantwortlich
sein
weil ich das hörte sie sprechen vom
präsidenten bis frei zugänglichen
kirchenbuch abgesehen davon ist ihr
sympathisch er machte diese unglückliche
aussage und ich fand da müsste man etwas
machen das ist wirklich zu viel gegangen
steckt etwas dahinter und wir werden uns
spielen wir mal mit der männer und
frauen rolle und dem bild gottes und
machen die einen sketch um das thema
weiter zu treiben
ich persönlich finde gott hat kein
geschlecht aber es gibt die beiden
energien männlich und weiblich
das sagt man ja auch von gott
ich fand einfach interessant mich über
gewisse ansichten über die frauen lustig
zu machen zu finden
die reaktion auf so was gibt es denn da
nicht auch strenggläubige besorgen
geht nicht gibt's da reaktion das gibt
es praktisch jeder hat doch eine rote
linie und auf unterschiedlicher höhe
bei einigen liegt die latte recht hoch
und solche episoden gehen durch aber es
gibt auch leute bei denen diese rote
linie er eng gefasst ist und bleibt dann
schon reaktionen
wer rot doch ganz nah also da merken sie
auch dass religion religiöse gefühle
sind sind wirklich verletzt wurde
ja klar es ist sicher kein einfaches
thema
unser ziel ist es solche leute nicht zu
verletzen
wir wollen bloß mit den rollenbildern
spielen und das ist ein wenig später in
dieser folge oder kommt eine stimme aus
dem himmel dass daneben eine weibliche
stimme das heißt sie wollen fragen
könnte das nicht alles auch anders sein
es gibt ja viele religiöse bedeutung und
hier setzen wir an
es gibt es religiöse und spirituelle
manchmal stimmt es über ein und manchmal
halt nicht erinnern ein
paternalistisches bild von gott hat wird
man alles anschauen
immerhin wurde die bibel ja von männern
geschrieben und dann schreibt man halt
auch über eine paternalistische sicht
aufbaut muss eben weitergeschrieben
werden
ein evangelium von heute auf andere auch
wenn man gott auch weibliche züge zu
friebe wo führt das hin
vielleicht zu einer päpstin ich finde
die vorstellung unglaublich lustig die
dinge etwas um und es trägt ein ganz
klein wenig dazu bei zum grundsätzlichen
zu kommen
es ist ja nicht die basis unserer
religion aber es steht doch mit man muss
auch sagen ich bin reformiert hier gibt
es die kultur der debatte und man kann
auch einmal
über die tabuzonen hinausgehen um darauf
zu kommen was dem glauben ausmacht
dieses grundsätzliche vertrauen ohne
dogmen und ganz klar definiert die
identität
wenn jetzt über ihr projekt gesprochen
was das mit kirche zu tun hab mit der
pastorin mit dem skeptiker
können sie mir sagen sie bauen was schon
ein paar jahre
was hat sich für sie verändert in dieser
zeit haben sie sich verändert oder ist
das rezept letztlich zu hören und die
andere person einfach sein lassen
ich persönlich hatte sich stark
verändert wirklich ich kann nicht wie
eine mauer vor einer pfarrerin stehen
ob ich jetzt mit ihr einverstanden bin
oder nicht der gopal k
wir sind ein paar kobler und in einer
symbiose
wir wachsen zusammen sombrero llanos was
hat sich verändert
komplett ganz konkret ist mein blick auf
den glauben auf liebe durchlässiger
geworden
[Musik]
sehr beeindruckt wenn die leute etwas
glauben kann das manchmal war werden
weil sie ihre energien bündeln und ich
hinterfrage mich auch mehr bei fragen
die früher für mich völlig klar war was
ich bei mir durchgängig geändert hat das
ist vielleicht verlange ich jetzt mehr
von alten denkmustern von theologischen
überlegungen zum beispiel warum brennt
man kann sagen dass er logisch aber er
eröffnet mir neue welten im denken in
der philosophie auf die ich vielleicht
nicht ohne weiteres käme wenn man in der
kirche ist besteht die gefahr dass man
immer etwa die gleichen dinge liegt das
was einen interessiert
das ist auch normal aber er erst singt
mich auch ein anderes zu denken und das
verändert mich natürlich auch ich kann
ihnen ein beispiel
er hat mir ein buch zum lesen gegeben
sapiens eine kurze geschichte der
menschheit das wirklich das auseinander
nimmt was die religion bewirkt das
fordert mich heraus
ich habe eine bestimmte religion und wie
kann ich heute noch predigen und dabei
im einklang bleiben mit der modernen
welt und dem fortschreiten der
geschichte schön ist sehr anregend los
erst die sagen für dieses gespräch und
für diesen einblick hinter die kulissen
ihrer web serie erzählt wie viel komik
oder satire darf sein wenn es um
religion geht das ist eine frage die
auch im nächsten film beitrag eine rolle
spielt bei den so genannten daten tätern
das sind junge frauen und männer aus
berlin muslime und nichtmuslime mit
esprit entlarven sie vorurteile
gegenüber muslimen und gegenüber den
islam wie es funktioniert sehen sie
selbst
[Musik]